hi everyone I'm Chris law and I'm a
product manager here at Google cloud my
mission is to make it easier for our
customers to do more on cloud with less
effort I'm excited to be here today to
tell you about active assist and how it
helps you do that look cloud can be
complicated you know it we know it
everyone knows it for many of you it can
sometimes feel like cloud has more knobs
and dials than this cockpit does and
this complexity can be overwhelming
we've seen that almost half of c-suite
executives said that complexity was the
factor that would have the most negative
impact on their cloud computing ROI over
the next five years in fact in some
cases complexity can make the cost of
administration and maintenance higher
than the costs of software and hardware
when we dig into the effects of
complexity we see a few big buckets
first complexity can cause waste things
like VMs are over provisioned and
discounts aren't optimized all leading
to unnecessary costs second complexity
can cause security gaps we see things
like access permissions being given away
too freely and firewall rule
configurations that are so confusing
that people are afraid to change them
finally all of this ends up causing lots
of extra work
things get misconfigured and now you've
got to spend your team's time trying to
figure out how to troubleshoot at all
now what makes this worse is that some
of the traditional approaches that
people take to solve these challenges
don't work well or don't scale some
companies try to keep hiring more people
to address the problem but the reality
is that the talent pool available is
small it takes forever to hire we at
Google face this issue to other
companies go ahead and just buy more
resources but that ends up being
unsustainable and adds more complexity
and finally some others have tried just
to write more code or widgets to help
but we hear from them that maintaining
that code is costly and ultimately it's
not their core mission at Google we
believe the answer is intelligence in
automation
today's IT environments whether on Prem
are in the cloud feel like a car for the
1970s everything is manual and you've
got to look over your shoulder shift
manually look at a paper map all are
getting bad gas mileage we want to
upgrade your cloud and provide
experiences like modern cars and beyond
how can we provide tools like blind spot
sensors and GPS that make your current
cloud experience markedly better
ultimately we're on a journey to a
future where we
to be able to automate everything for
you what happened overnight but we are
looking to move your cloud forward in
the same way that Google's way Moe is
moving cars forward we're excited to
introduce you to active assist here to
actively assist you so what is active
assist it's a new solution that brings
together an array of intelligent
features which all have a common goal to
make it easier for you to optimize your
cloud while reducing manual effort the
best of both worlds right we asked
ourselves what can we do to empower
customers with better intelligence and
automation and after speaking with many
of you we heard three answers loud and
clear first you want to find out what
went wrong quickly so you can take
action right away
second you want to prevent mistakes from
happening altogether and third you want
to improve your cloud easily by doing
this we can deliver on three big things
for our customers first we're going to
give you more ways to understand how to
optimize your resources and let you
automate that second we're gonna help
you proactively secure your cloud by
alerting you to things that need fixing
before they become a bigger issue and
third all of this aims to make your
lives easier by reducing the time and
toil that troubleshooting analyzing
configuring and administering your cloud
usually takes at the end of the day
active assist aims to help you maximize
your clouds overall performance without
you having you be on the hook to
understand every nook and cranny of your
cloud your cloud should work for you and
that's what we aim to do by helping you
automatically optimize your resources
for example we've had customers like
view clip who have been able to take
advantage of recommendations to quickly
optimize their VMs and save money it's
not enough to save money though today
security is also top of mind for
everyone we're in an age where
organizations have more and more
sensitive customer information and hacks
can be devastating
no organization wants to be on the
receiving end of that with active assist
we're going to help you proactively
identify security gaps and maintain best
practices in fact we've had large
customers who were able to use Identity
and Access Management roll
recommendations to help make their
environments more secure while reducing
the number of permissions that were
granted active assist will help you by
using automation intelligence to bring
key actions right to your fingertips it
takes away the guesswork in the mystery
that's normally required to operate your
cloud for example customers like HIPAA
ball we're able to use Network
Intelligence Center to
quickly troubleshoot network
configuration issues by now you may be
asking okay but house activists is gonna
do all this the fun answer is that
active assist is going to unlock Google
magic across your cloud we're gonna use
our specialties around data analytics
and machine learning to power active
assist active assist is a set of
features that cuts across Google cloud
so whether you're interested in security
cost networking compute data or our
newest offering anthos we'll be rolling
out a number of features to help to show
you some practical examples of this I'm
going to turn it over to daemon Melnick
who's a product manager on our team
thanks Chris hi everyone I'm excited to
show you how some of this intelligent
features that live under the active
assist umbrella can help you solve some
of the practical day-to-day challenges
you face and to do this I'm going to
tell you a little story this is Steve
and he is in charge of an application he
helped to architect and set up the
infrastructure for this application and
it's been smooth sailing so far this set
he built it for normal times but now
with people generally at home or buying
patterns changed almost overnight
skyrocketing the traffic to their
application and scale is hard Stevie's
and his colleagues face a number of
challenges with their applications
performance cost and secured him first
thing in the morning he gets a call from
Alice who is in charge of their customer
support department Alice tell Steve they
get slammed with customer calls over the
weekend complaining about terrible lot
times in overall slowness and as Steve
starts to think about what could be
causing those performance issues he
contemplates a couple of places where
they could be hiding is it
compute capacity or perhaps networking
or the data infrastructure layer that he
knows was architected with some duct
tape maybe it's not even caused by the
cloud infrastructure he's in charge of
at all honestly it could be anything and
the clock is ticking and Steve needs to
move fast he is worried that going down
the checklist might take way too much
time and effort while his users continue
to experience slowness and downtime
Steve is not really exactly sure what
about what to do next
but then he remembers a new
solution that might be able to help
active assist he recalls that active
assist goal is to help folks like him
optimize their cloud with
recommendations and other tools which
reduce an administrative overhead this
sounds really promising so he pulls up
the recommendation hub in the Google
Cloud console she was pretty excited
right away he is saying some some
recommendations on how to optimize
resources in his project for performance
and high availability he had the feeling
that computer resources on his project
might be overloaded with all this new
demand so he navigates to the VM right
sizing recommendations first he can
immediately see that many VMs on on this
project have recently had extremely high
CPU utilization which can definitely
result in long queues and negatively
impact the overall performance of his
application and this all is based on
Google Cloud performing multiple
simulations to select the replacement
VMs optimal for Steve's workload so he's
confident to apply this recommendations
almost feels too good to be true things
like this used to take a lot more time
to investigate and fix and yet this can
now be done with only a few clicks now
Steve is thinking about how to best deal
with these spikes in demand just like
the one they saw over the weekend going
forward so he turns to the next
intelligent feature in active assist
arsenal Steve already relies on compute
engine real time out of scaler but it
appears though that it doesn't work well
for his analytic java application which
takes more than five minutes to
initialize this auto scaling latency
contributes to the availability issues
that some of his users have reported so
he enables predictive at a scalar which
forecasts future capacity needs based on
historical load data and starts up VM
instances ahead of upcoming demand
awesome
Steve just took another manual task off
his plate next he looks into the other
healing feature as his team's frequent
on-call person Steve is definitely not
looking to get paged in the middle of
the night because of an application
crash caused by a recent bad update
memory overflow or something else to
prevent this from happening he creates a
simple health check and enables compute
engines utter healing this feature will
automatically recreate unhealthy VMs to
reduce the risk of any downtime and the
best thing it
works for his stateful workload
preserving his applications data now
that he has addressed his applications
compute capacity issues that have been
contributing to the poor performance
Steve decides to go deal with that
original issue that Ellis has reported
where some of their users in Europe were
impacted more than the rest of the world
he suspects this problems might be
caused by the network and he isn't the
networking expert and Steve would
typically hand something like this off
to the networking team for investigation
but as he's fighting the clock he
decides to open the network intelligence
center and see what he can find out on
his own so he looks at the performance
dashboard and quickly confirms that
everything within GCP looks good so he
opens up the network topology view to
investigate if there are any problems
for the external access that might be
contributing to the highlight and say
from this view he can immediately see
that something is wrong there users in
Europe are for some reason being served
from the non-optimal US central one
region he gives a quick call to his
friend on the networking team and they
quickly realize this must have been
caused by the oversubscribed pool of
computer resources which resulted in the
global load balancer automatically
rerouting traffic to the US they
remediate this issue quickly by adding
more resources in the Europe region and
reconfiguring the load balancer and
while on this topic of the networking
optimization opportunities Steve also
notices this VPN tunnel over utilization
recommendation this wasn't even top of
mind but fixing this now could prevent
major headaches later looks like one of
the VPN tunnels on his project has been
approaching its utilization capacity and
is likely to turn into a bottleneck
within the next few days so he
proactively notifies the networking team
to make sure they look into adding some
redundant said before this over utilized
VPN becomes a real problem now Steve
also had a hunch that his data
infrastructure might not have been
optimally set up either octopus's helped
him to identify one more immediate
opportunity to optimize his system for
resiliency it turns out that one of his
teams has been using BigTable without
backing up data if one of Steve's
developer colleagues makes a mistake in
their business logic and writes some
in the critical table it can be very
difficult to recover from that state
following this recommendation with just
one click
still creates a data flow job to
continuous that back up BigTable data in
the cloud storage to make sure it can be
restored in the event of a system
failure or let's face it user error this
seems like another major improvement
that will let him sleep through the
night
page free so Steve calls Alice and tells
her about a number of important changes
to the applications back-end he
implemented to remediate all the
performance issues reported by their
customers they both are relieved that
all this changes were made in just a
couple of hours and with basically no
labor's investigation custom scripts or
any significant administrative overhead
excited Steve goes back to his desk and
continues poking around other
optimization opportunities he discovers
that in addition to applying active
assist recommendations from within the
Google Cloud console he can also query
the recommender API directly and
incorporate them as a part of his
organization's existing workflow so he
decides to go the extra mile and write a
good custom script that will that pulls
new recommendations from the recommender
API and delivers the digest to his inbox
on a weekly basis Steve also shares the
script with his colleagues who run other
projects to help them proactively
address some of these performance issues
as well but wait as soon as he is done
helping Alice manage this initial
performance application performance
crisis
he has got Bob their finance director
knocking at his door Bob this for
everyone across the company to cut their
costs by at least 25% Stephen never
really liked Bob but they sit down
together to think through a few cost
optimization opportunities first there's
the total cost of ownership perspective
is it time to start really tackling
their self-manage stack and go
completely cervelas or maybe they should
go use a different database service well
it could be ways for them to optimize
their current resources but how can they
do this without sacrificing their
applications performance and
availability and finally there's the
pure finance angle with all the cloud
products Steve's team is relying on
there's a lot of complexity
on the billing side alone with literally
hundreds of billable fishers a number of
pricing models and discounts to pick
from
just like troubleshooting performance
issues cost-cutting can be really hard
and can take up a lot of time and effort
short of gathering a team of architects
DevOps and finance folks still decides
to go take a look at what active assist
has to offer in this space so he pulls
up a recommendation hub and focuses on
cost optimization cards this time right
away he is saying some recommendations
for his applications computer resources
storage and billing and he is already
familiar with the right sizing
recommendations for performance so he
starts with the ones that look very
similar but appear to be geared towards
cost savings Steve realizes there is a
number of VMs on his project that are
way too large for the tasks that they
have been initially allocated for he
applies this recommendations realizing
substantial savings from removing this
extra compute capacity his project
didn't really need after
provisioning he turns to the and the
austere and news resources this turns
out to be another major contributor to
the high cloud spend on his project this
recommendations indicate that he has got
a lot of idle VMS on his project
possibly from previous testing or
development cycles he didn't expect to
see this many but he's not really
surprised as he knows how easy it is for
people to spin up a VM and forget about
it and while on this topic hilsa comes
across another type of vital resource
recommendation turns out there are quite
a few persistent disks on his project
that haven't been utilized either he
realizes substantial savings by deleting
most of those idle PDS and archiving the
rest into cold storage and still is glad
that they won't be paying for all this
a Neos resource is going forward and
proceeds to look at the billing model
optimization opportunities to further
reduce costs he looked into this
committeth use discount concept a few
months ago but it seemed just way too
hard to operationalize before active
assist he had to do a lot of things on
his own starting from understanding
their team's current usage patterns to
figuring out trade-offs versus their the
current billing model which leverages
sustained use discounts and finally to
projecting the impact of any potential
billing model changes so he is very glad
to see that active assist has already
done all this heavy lifting for him he
grabs the screenshot with projected
savings and sends an email to Bob the
finance director to get his approval to
switch from the on-demand pricing to a
three-year commitment which could slash
their compute cost by almost 50% as he
moves to the other billing model
optimization opportunities he sees that
active assist has more one has more
recommendations for his project they
have been using bigquery as a data
warehouse there as their application
data has been growing more and more
people have been using bigquery with
their current on-demand billing model
their cost has been steadily going up as
well this recommendation is for Steve's
project to consider switching to the
bigquery slot billing model where they
can run as many queries as they need on
a fixed amount of monthly slots based on
his team's usage history active assist
estimated they will save a lot on their
bill without negatively impacting
performance which is really important to
Steve
so he takes this out with Bob along with
his earlier proposal to switch to the
committed huge discounts for compute
engine they walk through the resource
optimizations that Steve has already
implemented which resulted in immediate
savings and also agreed on implementing
the billing model changes that are
expected to yield even more substantial
savings over time and as they wrap up
Bob asks Steve if he can help apply
similar techniques to other projects in
their organization Steve goes back to
his desk to read the manual and quickly
discovers there is big very expert
fissure which allows them him to dump
all this insights and recommendations to
a big hairy table and do custom analysis
across their entire organization Steve
is already familiar with bigquery since
they have been using it for a lot of
their operational data anyway so a few
hours later he sends Bob the finance
director a link to the dashboard in
Google Cloud in Google Cloud Data studio
that uncovers substantial cost savings
opportunities across multiple projects
in their organization having optimized
their cloud infrastructure for cost and
performance Steve turns to security his
organization never took security lightly
and Steve feels they have a good set of
in-depth security measures in place
provided their recent growth though as
well as their company's new work from
home configuration he missed up with
Molly who is in charge of their security
team together they sit down to reassess
their security measures and make sure
they are doing everything they can to
protect the sensitive information that
their customers are trusting them with a
couple of things come to mind as they go
down the list do people have the
permissions they need to do their jobs
but not more over granted permissions
can lead to incidents malicious in
nature as well as the ones caused by
simple unintentional human errors which
could also result in data loss or
infrastructure changes that can be
really hard to revert then there's the
networking layer Molly tells Steve she's
worried about this one especially after
reading a bridge about a competitor who
had an open port which permitted traffic
from an insecure zone which then went
through a misconfigured firewall other
any holes in their firewall
configuration and
a whole set of other considerations are
unproductive sensitive data as well as
their our very own power users who
present a high security risk if their
identities are compromised Steve knows
this issues can be really hard but he
feels optimistic since he already knows
that active assist should be able to
help this time around he looks at the
security related features and is excited
to see some identity access as well as
firewall related config recommendations
he decides to dig into the permissions
first still like many project owners out
there wants to enforce the principle of
least privilege when all the project
members have access only to what they
really need he knows though that solving
this at scale is really hard many things
can go wrong from breaking something
running in production to slowing his
teams down with way too much process it
is much easier said than done that's why
he's extremely excited to see active
assist Identity and Access Management
right sizing recommendations that go
beyond just removing in news permissions
by using machine learning algorithms to
figure out what permissions users really
need so he quit he quickly cleans up all
the inactive service accounts and also
grants smaller and granular roles to his
project members literally making
hundreds of accounts more secure with
only a few clicks and as he goes through
this process he realizes that he would
love to dig into a couple of additional
questions in the context of some of
these changes for example how can I see
who can act as the service account on my
project luckily active assist has him
covered in this one as well with policy
analyzer Steve is able to answer this
question and many more in addition to
the one he had in mind
he runs a couple of other queries which
vm's can John delayed who has write
access on this big query data sent it
feels like magic but wait a minute Steve
says a service account that is able to
access the big query data set that it
probably shouldn't he wants to remove
this service account access but wants to
make sure that he doesn't break anything
in the process with policy simulator he
can check the proposed policy changes
against the 90-day access history to see
if these changes would block any
essential access which was previously
used and just as Steve
shop with policy simulator he has
someone come to him with this dreaded
I'm getting a denial error problem this
seemingly simple issues can be
surprisingly hard to troubleshoot they
could be caused by a number of factors
could be a lack of a certain permission
or group membership or a combination of
I am and network policies causing this
denial so still is relieved to be able
to use the policy troubleshooter tool to
confirm that they that this particular
user never had any access granted to
them in the first place so he asked them
to a group which provides just the right
amount of access they need to do their
job still feels that he is now in the
position to not only establish the
principle of least privilege but
actually maintain it instead of simply
grounding all permissions to everyone
who comes to him with my access isn't
working type of an issue next he turns
to the network firewall is one of the
most fundamental protection layers
managing however is a major challenge
for Steve his firewall configuration
grew really complex as more and more
access was added over time so he's
afraid to even touch it as he knows that
well this will likely break something
that's why Steve is relieved to see this
firewall insights from active assist he
starts with the and the used firewall
rules which can potentially allow an
unwanted access and present a major
security risk to his organization Steve
then looks at the firewall optimization
insights octave assists also brings to
his attention things like unreachable
and misconfigured rules which could be
redundant he's happy to see this
insights as well as they help him
simplify his firewall configuration and
make it much easier to manage and
maintain going forward but as he cleans
up his firewall configuration this
thought crosses Steve's mind again what
if I break something in production by
doing this changes luckily active assist
has him covered in this one as well
using the connectivity test feature from
the network intelligence Center
Steve can double check the impact of
configuration changes as he applies them
and this gives him confidence in a
couple of especially tricky scenarios
where he wasn't 100% sure if it was ok
to remove a particular firewall rule
heaven his
firewall configuration optimized stiff
turns to one more security gap he heard
that their recent conference that
roughly thirty percent of annual
enterprise data breaches involved
phishing he knows he should look into
this but it stuffed her allowed and
enforce a policy around identification
with multiple teams systems and vendors
that his company is relying on the good
news is he can now turn to active assist
for help he enables a phone as a
security key recommendation for his
organization's most at-risk users like
the ones who have broad permissions and
a substantial blast radius if their
accounts are compromised and the best
thing it's free and only takes two
minutes to set up happy about the
substantial progress he was able to make
so quickly still sits down with Molly to
go over this important security gaps he
was able to close and it's a win-win for
everyone
the project team can still maintain the
flexibility and velocity thanks to the
efficient troubleshooting and analysis
tooling that active assist provides in
addition to the security insights and
recommendations themselves and the
security team is happy with the
substantially reduced attack surface
which is getting them much closer to
this zero trust environment that they
want Molly asked Steve it can if ik if
he can help make this work at scale with
other projects in their organization and
especially with their new get ops
approach to administering the most
sensitive parts of their cloud
infrastructure such as permissions they
want to use github to do everything
declaratively and centrally and Steve
already has the answer while looking
into the recommender hub even into the
recommender API and big very expert
earlier he came across this reference
solution in the documentation which can
help them do exactly what Molly is
asking for he downloads this reference
implementation from github polishes it
and a couple of hours later folks on
their security team start seeing some
recommendations presented as pull
requests against their configuration
stored in get to recap we looked at
several examples of how active assist
can help improve your workloads
performance availability and scalability
optimize your cloud infrastructure cost
and improve your security posture to get
started with active assist we encourage
you to visit our website and
recommendation have been in cloud
console to see if there are some
recommendations already waiting for you
now some of the features that we
highlighted today are only available in
limited preview if you are interested in
getting early access to all the new
features as they get developed we
encourage you to join our active assist
trusted tester group which is linked
from our website and finally check out
this cloud on-air sessions for deeper
dives into some of the features that we
talked about thank you so much for
joining us today